Okay, so good morning. Today we finish
the French Revolution trilogy.
So, we are focusing on Napoleon today.
And my argument to you today is that
Napoleon would not have been possible
without Robespierre.
Okay, so
to illustrate this point, let us do a
thought experiment. I am going to
present to you two individuals.
Okay?
And I want you to think about who is the
greater genius.
Who is the
more real leader? Okay, so let's look at
person A. Person A has a perfect memory.
That's the first
characteristic. He is able to have
instant recall. He or she is able to
absorb all the information that comes
his or her way and is able to retain it,
okay?
Second thing
is the ability to have priorities.
So, what's rare among really smart
people is the capacity to prioritize
what is important information and what
is not important information, to filter
things out. Okay, because once you have
the important information, you are much
more capable capable of making the
correct decisions.
All right? The third thing is the
strategic imagination.
So, a general is able to take all the
relevant information that he or she has
obtained and then
imagine the battlefield across multiple
nations.
He or she is able to imagine how the
battle will progress.
And the fourth is the idea of
flexibility. So, even though the general
has a plan, he or she is still flexible
during the battle. So, if the battle is
not going to going according to plan,
then he or she he or she will make
adjustments to the battlefield because
he or she has total battlefield
awareness, okay? So, these are the four
characteristics of a great leader.
Now, let's look at B. And B only does
one thing.
B is
I promote
the talented.
That's all B does. That's all B cares
about.
Uh so, who among these two individuals
do you think is the more
aware individual, the greater leader?
The stronger genius.
A or B?
Okay. So, obviously it's a trick
question, okay? It's obviously B.
Right? And so, what I'm going to do
today is explain why it's B. Because A
is Napoleon.
Napoleon, like Alexander the Great, like
Julius Caesar, is a genius of war.
He's able to completely imagine the
battlefield and come up with strategies
that are shocking, innovative, and
unique. That's Napoleon.
B is Robespierre.
All Robespierre cares about is promoting
and rewarding those who are true and
loyal to the revolution.
Okay? So, I'm making I'm I'm I'm today I
want I want to make the argument that
Robespierre is the greater man than
Napoleon.
So,
um
to illustrate this point, I want to ask
you a question, okay?
Let's just say that I'm a very rich man,
maybe I'm Jack Ma.
And I have a huge company.
I employ thousands of workers.
Um I'm extremely profitable. I have a
son. He's 18 years old, and he's
expected to inherit my company at 40,
50, okay? But I say to my son, I've a I
sit I sit him down, I have a very long
dinner conversation with him. I explain
to him,
um
"Son, it takes a particular type of
person to run a great company. It takes
dedication, it takes virtue, it takes
selflessness.
You're a great person. I love you
because you're my son. But you're not
qualified
to run my company.
I have a team of experts
who will replace me after I'm dead. I'm
sorry, son, but
you have to go do something else, okay?
Because, quite honestly, I don't think
you would even enjoy running my company.
Okay? So, that's a a thought experiment,
right? Now, let me ask you this
question.
China has 1 billion people.
Would there be anyone in China
who would think I'm a good father?
No one, okay?
That's why B is hard. Because B requires
a selflessness.
But not only that, but B requires
the capacity to ignore social values and
focus on what is good by itself.
Okay?
That's why B is harder than A.
And And quite frankly, A, in history,
we'll meet a lot of individuals like
that. Julius Caesar, Napoleon, Hitler,
uh even today, um
there are quite a few individuals like
A. But B is rare, all right? So,
let me explain why B is so rare and why
Robespierre was fundamental to the birth
of Napoleon. All right. So, we're going
to focus on a battle. And this is 1805.
Austerlitz.
This is considered Napoleon's greatest
battle.
Okay? The war The battle that made
Napoleon into a legend.
This is something called the War of the
Third Coalition. So, Napoleon, the
French, are up against three major
nations, right? The Austrians, the
Russians,
and the British.
The Prussians will come up come in at
some point to join the Third Coalition.
So, Napoleon needs to act first and
knock out both Russia and Austria before
the Prussians come in, because Prussia
is considered at this point the greatest
military in the world. All right? So,
this is Austerlitz, the battlefield. Let
me first give you um an overview of what
the battlefield looks like. First of
all, you have the Coalition forces
stationed on high ground, okay? These
are about 70,000 troops.
Napoleon is scattered, okay? He's got
his forces here, he's got his forces
here on the right. This This is the
right. And these are his main forces.
Okay, this is Napoleon. He He also has
about 70,000 troops.
So, they look even, but actually the
Coalition forces have a huge advantage.
One, because they're on high ground,
okay? Second is that they are coming
More forces are coming in from behind to
to bolster the forces.
All right? So, it looks in the beginning
like the Coalition forces will overwhelm
Napoleon.
Okay?
But
and so, what the uh no the um Coalition
forces are going to do is this. They see
the right flank of Napoleon it's weak.
So, what they will do is they will send
a right attack and overwhelm the right,
and then come behind Napoleon, and then
the other forces will come down to
envelop
um Napoleon. This This This This is what
we call a flanking um attack, okay? So,
that is the plan. And quite honestly,
this is the most logical, the most
reasonable strategy given the
circumstances.
What they don't know is this. Napoleon
anticipates that they will do this. It's
a trap actually, okay? Because what's
going to happen is
that as they come and attack, Napoleon
will now attack
the coalition's right flank.
And as the coalition tries to muster the
right flank,
the
cavalry will come in and split the
coalition into two, forcing them to
retreat, okay? That is the master plan.
The problem with this plan is the right
flank. The right flank needs to hold
against the coalition attack, otherwise
the coalition will just sweep in and
um outflank Napoleon.
Napoleon has this plan where coming in
to um bolster the right flank is his
marshal Davout
with 10,000 men.
Okay? The problem though is that Davout
is 100 km away. So, it has to be a
really quick march to the right flank,
okay?
Now, if he misses,
the coalition will just wipe out this
army.
But,
he does get here in time. He saves the
right flank, and then the rest of the
plan goes exactly according to
Napoleon's vision, his strategy. It is
perfect, okay? Perfect timing,
uh perfect attack, everything is
perfect. And as a result, this is
exactly what happens. Napoleon splits
the coalition in two, they're forced to
retreat, and then what will happen is
that Napoleon will sweep in and capture
this entire army,
okay? Once this happens, the war
is over.
The Russians and the Austrians are
forced to retreat. The Austrians sue for
peace, the Russians go home, okay? So,
this is considered one of the greatest
battles in human history. It is up there
with Alexander the Great's battles. This
is considered the defining achievement
of Napoleon. And there are certain
characteristics about this battle that
make it uniquely Napoleon, okay? The
first is is total battlefield
awareness.
That's the first thing. He is able to
imagine the entire battlefield even
before this battle starts. He knows
exactly where each unit will be, okay?
So, total battlefield awareness is what
makes Napoleon unique. What also makes
Napoleon unique at this time is the idea
of speed.
This is all happens very, very fast.
Um at this time in Europe, battles are
fought slowly and it's really
like two forces banging against each
other, okay? But this is really fast and
what you have is a lot of
maneuverability, okay?
Okay? Usually in the battlefield, the
army fights as one unit. What's amazing
about Napoleon is he's able to divide
his forces into different smaller armies
that operate independently but as part
of a larger vision.
Okay? So, Austerlitz is the defining
achievement of Napoleon's grand strategy
of war.
And if you go to military college, if
you want to be a general, you will have
to study this war, this battle in great
detail.
All right?
So,
the problem with this plan is that
um it should not have worked.
Okay? It is a reckless
and stupid way to fight a battle.
Because there are about 10,000
ways that it that that could go wrong,
okay?
First of all, you need this guy, Davout,
to come in.
He has to do about 110 km in 48 hours.
This is This was
This was before considered impossible.
A really strong army, really
disciplined, really well-trained will do
at most 20 km in one day.
Okay, think about that.
This is the best army in the world. The
Prussians will do 20 km in one day.
Davout is able to do 110 km in two days.
All right? And that just shows you how
extremely disciplined
the French are.
Not only are they able to do 110 km in
48 hours, but they come into the
battlefield fresh for battle, okay? They
jump straight into battle, and they are
pushing the coalition forces back.
So, it's an incredible achievement by
Davout. In fact, if you study um
military history,
you will see a lot of people argue that
Davout was the far superior general to
Napoleon.
Okay? Because it takes a lot of skill to
marshal your forces and organize them in
a way that they will want to march that
fast in that quick of a time, okay? So,
the first thing that must have happened
is Davout had to come in time. But, you
know what? There could have been rain,
right? He could have gotten lost.
An army could have come in and blocked
his his advance.
All right? So, 10,000 things could have
gone wrong. Napoleon was really lucky
that these things didn't go wrong.
Also, in this in
um this attack by the French,
it was possible
that the coalition could have
overwhelmed the attack, okay?
So, in other words, the thing about
Napoleon that's really important is,
yes, his strategic genius is one thing,
but what really matters is the officers
under him.
Okay? He had a really talented bench of
officers who were committed to the
battle, and they knew exactly
what they had to do.
Napoleon was the one with a vision. He
was the one who had the courage and the
boldness to attack, but it was they who
executed the plan perfectly.
All right? And that's the defining
characteristic of
the Grand Army of Napoleon.
All right? So,
let me explain to you how this happened.
Okay? How was it that the French was
able to build Europe's greatest army
during the French Revolution?
All right. So, let's compare the
Prussians and the French.
And the Prussians again are considered
at this time in European history the
greatest army ever.
All right? So, they are run by the
nobility.
The officers, the generals are nobility,
and they are called the Junkers. This is
very important. I want you guys to
remember the the the term Junkers. Okay?
They are the elite of Prussian society.
They're the ones who will take Germany
into World War I and World War II. Okay?
They're they're the force behind Hitler,
and they are considered
um the greatest warriors in European
history at this time, the Junkers.
They are landed nobility. They have
their land, and so they can focus
completely on warfare. And as time
progresses, they become the greatest
generals and officers of Europe at this
time. Let's look at the soldiers.
The soldiers come from three sources.
The first is conscription.
Okay? Conscription just means that you
draft people um from your nation to join
the war. Second is volunteers.
Why do people volunteer? Because you're
often treated better in the military
than you are um in the nation. If you're
a soldier, the nobility can't beat the
crap out of you for no reason. But if
you're a peasant, the nobility can beat
the crap out of you for no particular
reason. Okay? And the third, which is
the most con- controversial, are
deserters.
So, the Prussians have a nasty
reputation for arresting people who they
believe ran away from other armies like
the French and British Army and they are
forced into the Prussian Army.
It's like they basically prison.
Now they they have a nasty reputation
because a lot of these deserters are
actually not deserters. They just happen
to be people from neighboring nations
that the Prussians kidnap into their
army. Okay? So you have these three main
sources. Now
the thing that makes the Prussian Army
unique in Europe is it actually has very
strict requirements for joining
military. You have to be tall basically.
You have to be like 5'8". The average
height was like 5'6" at this time in
Europe. Napoleon himself was 5'7". You
have to be 5'8". Okay? So Napoleon would
not have been able to join the Prussian
Army. You have to be 5'8". It's the
tallest army in the world. The Prussian
King Frederick the Great has has has
takes tremendous pride in how tall his
warriors are.
Okay?
All right. So
um this extremely disciplined army, but
with this army comes three fundamental
weaknesses.
Okay? The first is
they can't afford
to lose that many men. Okay? These are
These men are extremely well trained.
They're extremely well disciplined. They
cannot afford to lose that many soldiers
in battle. Okay? That's the first
problem. Second problem is they're
extremely slow. Why are they slow?
Because
um the officers like to live well. Okay?
So So wherever they go, there's maybe
like three or four different trap wagons
that carry their food, carry their
clothing, carry their servants. Okay? So
this is a very slow army. But it's fine
because every other army in Europe is
slow as well. Okay?
Um and so this creates a problem of
inflexibility.
The Prussians fight one way and that's
the only way they fight. They basically
move up front and because of the
discipline of the soldiers, they
overwhelm their enemy.
They They have that much flexibility in
their army, okay? So, these are the
three fundamental weaknesses of a
Prussian army. They cannot afford
casualties, they're extremely slow, and
their strategy is inflexible.
All right?
But, it's not a problem because every
army in Europe suffers from the same
problems.
Now comes the French Revolution. Okay?
The French Revolution Robespierre takes
charge of organization and personnel
hiring basically for the new French
Revolution army. And he makes radical
changes
to the French military. The first is the
idea of meritocracy.
Okay. So, before, like every army, most
of the French army, the officers and
generals were of nobility that were
appointed by the king. They were loyal
to the king, and as such, Robespierre
saw them as a threat, right? So, he
basically replaced the nobility with
young men from the provinces who
believed in a revolution. So, at the
beginning of the revolution, about 85%
of all officers, French, were nobility.
Five years later, it's about 3%. That's
a huge, huge change, okay? One of One of
these men that that's recruited into the
French military and promoted very really
fast is Napoleon.
Napoleon, by the age of 25, is a
general. And that's unheard of at Europe
at this time. But, it's not just
Napoleon, it's like dozens and dozens of
really talented young men um who are
given opportunities they would not have
been given anywhere else. Also, what's
important for us to remember is that
Napoleon himself is not French. He's
Corsican.
Okay? He's a foreigner.
But, because of French Revolution, he's
given these tremendous opportunities.
All right? So, that's that's the first
thing, it's meritocracy.
Second thing is, it is total war.
In other words, it is complete
conscription.
There are no volunteers, there are no
deserters, it's everyone must now join
the army.
Okay? So, now France has almost endless
supply
of soldiers. And that gives the French
three major advantages. The first is
high casualties. They can actually
afford now to lose a lot of men in
battle. So, the French are now willing
to take risks that other armies are not
able to take. For example, Austerlitz,
right?
Austerlitz was a huge huge gamble that
paid out for the French. But, they're
able to do so because they're able to
replenish their forces if need be. Okay?
High casualties. Second is the idea of
mobility, speed.
All right? So, now you don't have any
you don't have any officers, where you
can travel really fast. Also, your
soldiers can just live off the land. You
don't have to feed them like great food.
They can just go and find berries or
chickens to cook for themselves, okay?
So, they are able to travel at least
three times as fast as their enemies.
That's an incredible advantage because
even before their enemies are able to
set up camp, the French have surrounded
them and overwhelmed them. Okay? And
this happens a lot during these wars.
So, speed is the crucial factor.
And the third
advantage is flexibility.
If you have an extremely dedicated army,
what you're able to do is you're able to
divide them into different units called
corps, okay?
Um this is no different from the Roman
legion. Uh the Roman legion was the
uh main tactic of the Roman army back in
the old days, okay? So, what what you do
is you take a huge army, you divide them
into smaller armies.
And if they're able to travel really
fast, what this army is able to do is
really quickly surround the enemy, okay?
If you surround the enemy, the enemy is
dead. The the the biggest problem in war
is being encircled because you've cut
off their supply routes, um
they don't know how to how to respond to
encirclement. Okay? So, the French for
many years was just destroyed enemies
because of these three factors. They're
able to take high casualties, their
speed, and their strategic flexibility
in battle, okay? And who created the
system? Robespierre created the system.
Robespierre. Not Napoleon, Robespierre.
All right?
So,
um
to give you an illustration of what the
difference is, let's go to year 1806.
Okay? So, the French have destroyed the
Austrians, the Russians are in retreat,
the Prussians come to battle now, okay?
And And all of Europe is like, "Oh, wow,
the Prussians now have taken the
battlefield."
The Prussians are going to overwhelm the
French because the French are just
peasant recruits, the Prussians are
tall, they're strong, they're fearless,
they're going to destroy the French,
okay? So, for the first time since the
revolution, the Prussians and the French
meet in 1806.
Okay.
Um it is a total and utter annihilation,
okay? Never before has Europe seen this.
The French in 30 days wipes out entire
Prussian army. It is incredible to
watch. Also, there's a very famous
battle during this time where Davout,
um he's a corp leader,
and he gets lost. And he ends up
fighting the entire
Prussian army.
Okay? You you you know about this
battle, right? Um and he's outnumbered
two to one. He wins the battle.
Davout is able to win uh outnumbered two
to one against the main Prussian army
led by the king himself, okay? So, this
is a radical revolution in military
affairs. The French, by using the
system, is able to dominate Europe for
uh most
of Napoleon's reign, okay? But But And
what this does is, and this is really
important, is
this because the French are dominating
the battlefield, it forces the other
European powers to make fundamental
changes to their society.
Because the French or the French
Revolution, these societies are forced
to become more liberal and democratic
and open and progressive in order to
defeat Napoleon. So, after 1806, the
Prussians make a lot of major changes to
their society, okay? What they recognize
is that our soldiers aren't enough. We
need to change the fabric and structure
of our society if we are to defeat
Napoleon, okay? So,
um they make two major changes. There
There's other changes, but there are two
major changes that that are fundamental.
The first is they abolish serfdom.
Okay? Serfdom.
Serfdom is basically like slavery, where
the peasants are tied to the land.
And that's the majority of people. When
you abolish serfdom, the advantage of
that is now you can have
more conscription. These peasants are
now able to come and become soldiers,
because serfs are not allowed to be
soldiers, okay?
So, now your army the numbers have
increased. And so, all the armies at
this time in Europe are increasing
because they're allowing more people to
join the military.
Okay, and the second, which is most
important, is the middle class.
So,
uh before the French Revolution, all of
Europe was extremely structured
stratified society. The nobility at the
top, but because of Napoleon's
victories,
the Prussians allowed the middle class
to join the civil service. That's
fundamental, okay? They're now
activating the energy of the middle
class. And this allows for innovation,
it allows for
um more uh economic activity.
And so, 1806, even though the Prussians
are destroyed,
it allows them to build a structure that
will allow them to dominate all of
Europe in about, you know, 50-60 years
time, and eventually they become the
dominant power in Europe and the world,
basically, uh before the beginning of
World War I. And this was all possible
because the Prussians lost to the French
and they learned lessons from the French
Revolution. Okay, that's why I keep on
saying the French Revolution was a
turning point in
uh human civilization, okay? So, that is
my main argument. Um are there questions
of about this argument?
I'm a little bit confused about uh the
serfdom
or the concept.
Like he means that the peasants can
join the army or
Okay, so serfdom, okay.
All right. So, the idea the institution
of serfdom, it's basically slavery where
peasants are tied to the land. They
cannot leave the land. And this is
important because, again, most of these
societies are agricultural-based. So,
you need people actually to work the
land.
And as such, your the majority of your
population is not eligible for the
military.
Okay, does that does that make sense?
When you eliminate serfdom, now every
man is eligible for the military. And as
such, you can um
replenish your forces. And a lot of men
want to join the military because it's a
lot better to be a soldier than it is to
be a peasant, right? As a soldier, you
you are
um given rights by the military, okay?
Because the military is a very powerful
institution. If you're a soldier, you
can't be pulled around by anyone.
Whereas where whereas if you're a
peasant, you're a serf, you I mean, you
you're like an animal.
Okay? So, if you if you give people a
choice whether or not to join the
military or be a serf, they would choose
to be a soldier. Even though there's a
risk of death, okay? But with a soldier
comes a possibility of social mobility
and social respect, which is not
available to you if you are a serf.
Okay, does that make sense? Great.
I got a I got a I got a question. Um the
So, like earlier on in the in the French
Revolution, there
there were wars against Prussia that
the the also won. And one of the
reasons for that that often come up
because is that they had like it was
ideological reasons that the
the French at that time were full of the
spirit of the French
That's right. That's right.
the ideology of it
Yep.
on nationalism and all that kind of
stuff, right?
Um
but we
move up 15 years into the Napoleonic
Yes.
period.
Are those ideal ideals of the French
Revolution still part of the army or is
it more of like a esprit de corps like
we're just a bunch of young men moving
up in the world and this is our new
identity as an imperial army?
Yeah. Okay, that's a good question,
okay. So the be- beginning of the
Revolution, these revolutionaries were
compelled by re- I'm sorry, religious
fever to die for the nation, okay? And
Robespierre became their role model
because Robespierre sacrificed himself
uh for uh for for France. Um but 1804,
what happens is Napoleon becomes
emperor. And once he becomes emperor,
everything changes.
Because now, you're not you're no longer
fighting for your nation, you're
fighting for your emperor.
And there are a lot of French people who
felt betrayed by Napoleon. So after
1804, this is really important, French
is still the greatest military in the
world, but it's basically a military
cabal
military cabal, okay, who run France. Uh
Napoleon is just the head of a group of
generals who love war, who benefit from
war, um and um as such, France becomes a
military nation where everyone's
supporting the French um
military adventurism, okay? And even
though the French do win a lot of wars,
eventually because you're an empire, you
just exhaust everyone, okay? But but but
I will discuss this during the PPT,
okay?
All right. So thank thank you. All
right.
Any more questions before I go into the
uh
PPT?
Okay. All right. So, one last point is
why is Robespierre creating a
meritocracy? Okay, the reason why he's
creating a meritocracy is, remember,
he's trying to create a new society. And
there are a lot of threats to this new
society. Obviously, the major threat is
these foreign armies like the Prussians,
the Austrians,
um the Spanish who want to restore the
Bourbon monarchy. That's a major threat.
Then you have these rebels,
uh these peasants who want to restore
the the privileges of the Catholic
Church. That's also another major
threat. But the main threat is actually
the army itself, right? Because
remember,
85% of the army is nobility. And there
were actually a few few times when the
army wanted to march against the
revolution and restore the monarchy.
And the generals didn't do that, even
though they wanted to, because they were
afraid that the soldiers would mutiny
against them. Okay, so this is a huge
problem for Robespierre, and that's why
Robespierre um spearheaded the movement
to replace no nobles with ordinary men
like Napoleon, which gave Napoleon the
opportunity to rise among
uh to to rise within the ranks, okay?
Does that make sense? That's the logic
of the revolution.
All right.
All right. So, um let us now go into the
details of this now that we've done an
overview.
All right.
So,
sorry.
All right.
So, the question we're looking at today
is how did a nobody, okay, and this guy
was lit- literally was a nobody. He was
from a from an island called Corsica,
which was not even French. It was part
of the French Empire, but it's not
actually French.
Um he grew up speaking French, but in a
in a very bad accent, okay? So, people
made fun of him in school. His family
was local nobility in Corsica, but they
were poor, Okay? So, this guy was
literally a nobody. And in only like, I
don't know, like a decade, he became
emperor of France, the French Empire,
which at that time was the um main power
in Europe. So, how was this possible?
How did a nobody Napoleon become emperor
of France? Okay. So, for us to
understand this, remember what the
French Revolution was. These three
classes we've looked at very closely at
the French Revolution, and my argument
to you is it was a religious crusade.
Yeah, this the
The irony, of course, is
the French Revolution was trying to re-
remove religion
from social life. Okay? But, if you look
at what actually happened in the French
Revolution, it was the ultimate
religious crusade, where the people were
willing to sacrifice their lives in
order to build a new society based
entirely on reason. Their new god was
reason. Okay?
Um
Another idea I want you to remember is
that mythologies are prophecies, and
prophecies are plans of action. Okay?
So, embedded in your subconscious are
the mythologies of society.
Um in France at this time, these
mythologies included the stories of
Jesus, but also the stories of Alexander
the Great and Julius Caesar. Napoleon
saw himself as the reincarnation
of both Alexander the Great and Julius
Caesar. And he wanted to create a
mythology that he was in fact the
Messiah.
Okay? So, these mythologies are there,
and Napoleon saw this as an opportunity
in order for him to amass power for
himself. That was his main insight,
okay? He was not a great general. That
is one of the major misconceptions out
there. He was not a great general. He
was not as good as the Pope was, but he
understood that the underlying framework
for society are mythologies. If you can
control these mythologies, you can
control people. You can become the
emperor, okay? That was his major
uh revelation.
All right. So, three things to remember,
mythologies are part of the collective
subconscious, okay?
We are all in society
governed by the mythologies that we
share together. That's the first idea.
Second idea is that when collective
subconscious Well, sorry. When
collective consciousness authority
breaks down, these mythologies begin to
drive history.
So, when you remove your teachers, it
doesn't mean no one's in charge. It just
means that now these mythologies are in
charge, okay? So, think of the Cultural
Revolution in China.
You could remove these authority
figures, but then your subconscious
takes charge. And the third idea is
certain individuals will act out the
leading roles in these mythologies and
capture the imagination and attention of
everyone else, okay? That's why Napoleon
became emperor, because he saw that the
French were looking for a Messiah.
And he And he's like, "I will become
your Messiah."
And he did that by acting it out, by
pretending to be Alexander the Great, by
pretending to be Julius Caesar, okay?
Now, I'll show you how later on. Okay,
so that's the main idea we're looking at
today. All right. And Napoleon himself
said this, okay? This is a very famous
quote that he said
while he was in exile in St. Helena,
okay? So, he's basically writing his
memoirs. He's reflecting on his life,
and he's not that perceptive. He's not
that bright. But, in this quote, we see
his
plan, his like like how he became
emperor, okay?
Let's Let's read this. "I saw the way to
achieve all my dreams.
I would found a religion, right? He's
not like, "I'm not a general. I am a
religious leader.
I saw myself marching into Asia, mounted
on elephant, a turban on my head." That
is Alexander the Great. That's actually
Caesar, okay?
"And in my hand, a new Quran that I
would have composed to suit my needs." A
Quran, a Bible, okay? So, that's what he
saw So, he understood what the French
Revolution really was. It was a crusade
to bring reason into the world, and he
would become the Muhammad,
the Julius Caesar, the Alexander the
Great, the Jesus that would achieve
this crusade.
Okay, does that make sense? He
understood this from the beginning, and
that's why he was able to succeed.
Whereas Robespierre,
um he may have understood this, but he
refused to act out that role.
Right?
All right. So, even even in his
beginning in in the beginning of his
career, he was focused on creating
mythology of himself. This is This is
when he was first a general and was part
of the Italian campaign.
And this is a mythology of him leading
his warriors into battle, okay? This
didn't really happen this way. Doesn't
matter. Because he understood
that what matters is how people people
perceive you. The reality The underlying
reality reality doesn't really matter.
So, when he was emperor, he was focus
focusing on a cult of personality, okay?
Paintings of himself, stories of of
himself that would
um become the official history. So, a
lot of stuff that we know about
Napoleon, his victories, we have to be
suspicious about, okay? Because he was
so focused on creating a myth of
himself, okay?
All right.
So,
um
let's go over some details that we
discussed, all right?
So, um when Louis the 16th was in
charge, the French army had a lot of
problems. The first problem was you had
too many generals. 500 678 generals,
480,000 men. That's a lot of generals.
Okay? And the reason why they had these
generals is they were friends of the
king.
They were incompetent, they weren't
necessary, but the king liked them. And
so, the king promoted them, right? It
was It's a way to ensure the nobility
was loyal to you.
But that made for a top-heavy
um bureaucracy that
didn't allow for innovation and change,
okay? So, that's that's the first
problem. Second problem is 85% are
noble, harsh discipline,
soldiers didn't want to fight, they were
forced to fight.
No conscription, volunteer army,
basically deserters, 1/3 would desert
every year.
Okay, 1/3 of soldiers would would run
away every year. So So that's why this
army
is problematic, okay? And that's why the
Prussians, the English would defeat the
French in many battles before the
revolution.
All right.
So this man is named
Carnot.
And he's actually a friend of
Robespierre's. They were They became
friends when Robespierre
was in his provincial town of Arras.
They They've known each other for like a
long, long time. And when when
Robespierre became prominent in the
revolution,
he asked his friend Carnot to come up
with a new system of reorganizing the
military. And Carnot came He's a
mathematician, a scientist. He came up
with the idea of conscription. Let's
call it a levy en masse. So let's get
everyone to join the military so as to
dilute the influence of nobility. And it
worked spectacularly well. And because
he he he's a mathematician, he was
extremely well organized, okay? He is
one of the main conspirators against
Robespierre um because he when he
amassed power, he recognized that he
couldn't really benefit from his power.
Robespierre was too virtuous. He
demanded on everyone making sacrifices.
And so these people that Robespierre
promoted, that Robespierre favored,
would eventually conspire against him,
okay? And one of these men is Carnot.
And Carnot is is also important because
Carnot would make Napoleon a general.
Right? So the thing about Napoleon
that makes him distinctive in the
military is he's very good at
um
um coming close with political patrons,
okay? He's very good at identifying
political patrons and getting them to
help him in his career.
All right. So as you can see, because of
conscription, the French army is
increasing, and that forces the other
armies of Europe to increase as well.
Okay? So, you can see the spike.
Um during this time, because all of all
these reforms in military, many young
great generals are merging in the French
military. So, Napoleon is the most
famous, but there are others who
actually just as good or even better
than Napoleon. Okay? Dozens of them. And
they These generals will become the core
of the French military.
All right?
And all of them are driven by a
Republican
idealism. Okay? They want France to
become a republic. They want France to
be France to be free. They want to
spread the revolution all across the
world. And not not not not not only are
they
um devoted and idealistic, but also
their soldiers. Their soldiers are
willing to die in battle, whereas the
others are whereas other nations are
not.
Okay? Um the Vou we talked about, okay?
Without the Vou, there's no way Napoleon
could have won his battles. The Vou is
probably the greatest general at this
time.
Um
so
so Carnot makes
Napoleon a general. And why is Napoleon
given given the generalship? Because
Napoleon does
the
Carnot a favor. So, after Robespierre's
death, a directory is set up to be
basically be the dictatorship of France.
Okay? Five-man dictatorship, which
includes Carnot,
and
um also Paul Barras, who is also another
patron of Napoleon, as well as a friend
of Robespierre.
Okay? And at first, after Robespierre's
downfall, both Paul Barras and Napoleon
are under investigation, because they
are friends of Robespierre. But because
they are extremely political
politically flexible I mean he he is the
opposite of Robespierre. Robespierre was
virtuous. He's very cynical. Okay, he's
he's your perfect political operator.
Okay, he's able to become one of the
leaders of the directory and he helps
promote Napoleon's career. Napoleon
helps them because at this time there's
a mob a Paris mob that threatens the
directory. Okay, and what Napoleon does
is he fires cannon at them. Okay, and as
a general you're not supposed to do
that. You're not supposed to like
actually go kill your own people. But
Napoleon he is ambitious. He's merciless
and he so the directory owes him a favor
and he asks for a generalship of the
Italian Peninsula. Why? Because that's
where Julius Caesar is from, right?
And in the Italian Peninsula
he wins a lot of battles. The record
is mixed. It's not as great as people
make it out to be. Okay, but after the
Italian Peninsula what's interesting is
he then goes to Egypt.
Why? Because Alexander the Great went to
Egypt and Julius Caesar went to Egypt.
Okay, so even at this particular stage
in his career he understands how to
create a mythology of himself, right?
I am the new Julius Caesar. I'm the new
Alexander Alexander the Great. And it
works. Okay, because in 1799
Paul Barras
as well as
Emmanuel Sieyès who is now the head of
the government they get sick of the
Republic. The Republic it's corrupt.
It's ineffectual. They want to establish
their own dictatorship. But for them to
establish their dictatorship they need a
general to help them out. Okay? So they
need the army on their side and they go
to different individuals. They go to
first General Moreau who is right now
considered the best general in
France. He's the most respected and
Moreau would decide with them they would
have no issues with their coup d'état.
But Moreau, he's a staunch Republican.
He refuses. He's like, "No, this goes
against the revolution. This goes
against the legacy of Robespierre. I
refuse to join in your coup d'état."
So then they go to McDonald, okay?
At this point, McDonald is like, "I
don't want to do this, but have you
talked to Napoleon?" Okay? And so they
go talk to Napoleon, and of course
Napoleon wants to do this. Napoleon's
been dreaming about this. He wants to be
the new Caesar who crosses the Rubicon
and ends the Roman Republic.
Okay? And so what happens is Napoleon
launches a coup d'état in Paris. And at
this point, the great fear is the mob of
Paris will rise up against Napoleon. But
they don't.
Because
Napoleon has done such a great job of
creating mythology of himself as a
Messiah, right? And at this point, after
the death of Robespierre, people are
looking for a Messiah.
So
Napoleon gets away with it.
And then what he does is he knows that
now that he's dictator, he needs to
fulfill people's mythology of of him as
Messiah. So rather than just sit sit and
enjoy being emperor, he decides to go to
Italy again, okay? So the first thing he
does, which is really interesting, is he
crosses the Alps.
He crossed the Alps. Why? Because
Hannibal crossed the Alps.
Okay? And during in Italy, he makes a
lot of really stupid decisions. Okay, so
for example, um he had the Austrian army
encircled.
Okay? So he had different
forces surrounding the Austrian army.
And what Napoleon was afraid of is the
Austrian army would run away.
But if you're a general in the Austrian
army, you recognize that the French are
divided, right? So I just I just
bulldozed them, okay? So the Austrians
launch this massive attack against the
French, and the French are now being
overwhelmed. But the But the French have
incredible discipline, so they hold the
line, but they're still being
overwhelmed because they're outnumbered,
okay? Napoleon comes in with his elite
group with his elite soldiers. The elite
soldiers hold their line, but 50% of
them are killed. And so now the
Austrians are just bulldozing the
French, right? Napoleon is saved because
an- another French army is able to come
in and save them.
Okay? So, Napoleon is taking all these
stupid risks
uh for no particular reason, and it's
all to create a mythology of himself as
this great conqueror. Because what he
recognizes is, I don't have to win this
battle because I control the government.
When I'm When I go back to France, I'll
just tell everyone I won, and everyone
will believe me. But what's important is
action, okay? I need action in order to
create my mythology.
All right? So, after this Italian
campaign, what he does next is
um create a legend of himself as the new
Messiah who will lead lead the French
people into the promised land.
Okay?
Um this is the Battle
of Marengo, where Napoleon should have
been destroyed, but he got lucky again.
And in 1804, he makes himself emperor of
France, and this now destroys the
revolution. Because the Messiah is not
supposed to do this. The Messiah is not
supposed to make himself emperor. The
Messiah is supposed to be selfless, like
Robespierre, and lead the people to
victory, to free the entire world.
You're not supposed to become emperor,
okay? Because once you become emperor,
you have worldly needs. He makes now his
brothers
emperors as well. He makes his brother
Joseph emperor of Italy as well as
Spain.
Okay? He then makes his other other
brother So, this is Joseph. Um he then
makes his other brother Louis king of
Holland, okay? So, he's basically
dividing up Europe among his family
members.
And obviously, if you are a French
revolutionary who dedicate your entire
life to promoting
uh liberty around the world, you don't
see this as a good thing, right?
All right. So,
the other thing about um Napoleon is he
was an extremely selfish individual. He
was narcissistic. He was He was selfish.
The reason why we know this is one thing
that he spent a lot of time on is
writing letters to his wife, the Empress
Josephine. Okay? So, let's just le-
let's just read certain sections of
these letters.
So, he writes to Josephine, "Since I
left you." Okay, he's he's in campaign
right now in Italy. "I have been
constantly depressed. My happiness is to
be near you." Okay, so he's obsessed
with Josephine. Okay? He's He's a
general. He's in charge of tens of
thousands of soldiers, but he every day
he's thinking about, "Hey, is Josephine
sleeping with another man?"
It's like literally what he's thinking.
He's He's like, "I know Josephine's
sleeping with another man, and I'm going
to I'm going to be really angry when I
find out." Okay? That That's what he's
thinking every day. And we know because
"I don't love you anymore. On the
contrary, I detest you. You are a vile,
mean, beastly slut."
All right? So, this is This is what he's
writing to his wife who's sleeping with
other men while he's away on campaign.
Also,
"My mistresses do not in the least
engage my feelings. Power is my
mistress." So, this is a megalomaniac.
He's narcissistic. He's obsessed with
obtaining with obtaining as much power
as possible. That's what drives him.
And what he recognizes is this.
In order for him to maintain his
mythology, in order for him to maintain
his image as a Messiah, he France needs
to be constantly at war.
So, even though
um Napoleon could at this time just
enjoy being emperor, instead he's
constantly at war with everyone in order
to
uh maintain his mythology. Because the
mythology is what controls the French
people. If you don't have the mythol-
mythology, they won't let you become
emperor anymore, okay?
And so, as a result, France becomes the
largest empire
in Europe. Okay? So, the blue, the light
blue, it's all part of the French
empire. He's controlled France, but he
controlled Spain, Italy,
um parts of Prussia, Germany.
Okay? And
but the problem with Europe is, as I
mentioned in previous classes, the
geography. It's very hard to control all
of it. So, Britain is still impossible
to conquer. Right now, Britain has the
greatest navy in the world. France has
the greatest land army in the world, but
Great Britain has the greatest navy in
the world, and therefore they can never
be invaded. Okay? Russia is just too big
to be invaded. There's still Austria
around. Um and so,
now the French army, it is overextended,
and people have lost their revolutionary
fever. Okay? They don't want They don't
want to die anymore for Napoleon. So,
now the French army, they're fighting
all these battles, they're losing a lot
of men, and they're and and these men
are being replaced with just common
people who don't really care about
fighting. Okay? So, now the French army
is in decline.
Um the turning point, of course, is in
the year 1812. And that's that's the
year when
um Napoleon decides to invade Russia.
And even though
um the invasion is a failure, he's still
able to escape.
The problem though is that in Russia,
he's lost his cavalry. He no He no He no
longer has cavalry in battle. Okay? So,
that's a huge disadvantage. Also, his
soldiers soldiers are fighting a
guerrilla warfare in Spain. Because
what's happened is, because of
Napoleon's conquest, nationalism is on
the rise.
Before, people fought against Napoleon
in order to restore the French monarchy
in order to stop the revolution. Now
people are fighting against Napoleon in
order to secure the national
independence from the French. Okay, in
order to practice their religion, in
order to protect their national values.
And so the Spanish rise against the
French Napoleon, but also the Germans as
well. So now Napoleon is way
overextended and he no longer has the
military that he once had um during the
revolution.
Okay?
All right. So
um eventually Napoleon is defeated. Um
this is called the Congress of Vienna
and it will lead to something called the
Concert of Europe. And this
um peace
is being masterminded by a man named
Met- Metternich, okay? And Metternich
argues for balance of power. Let's just
maintain our borders
and let's no longer fight any more wars
because
the because Napoleon, his wars killed
millions of people. We are sick and
tired of war. The people are are sick
and tired of war. That's why Napoleon
was defeated because people wanted
peace.
Now
um so this Concert of Europe, this peace
agreement, and we can think of this as
as actually like a proto-United Nations,
okay? An organization dedicated to
maintaining balance of power in Europe.
It worked extremely well.
The uh Napoleon is defeated in 1815 at
the Battle of Waterloo and after that
there's no more wars in Europe, okay?
Until maybe 1856 during the Crimean War,
okay? That's like 40-50 years.
So it's an incredibly successful
formula. The problem though is this.
If you don't let people fight wars, what
are they going to do? They're going to
revolt against you.
Okay? So because of inequality, you have
all this massive tension in society. So
your options are either you take people
to war and kill off a lot of people or
these people will rise up against you,
okay? And that's what happened in 1848
during the revolutions when all of
Europe was engulfed in revolutions. We
will study this later on, okay? But I I
want you to remember this idea.
1815,
the Congress of Vienna, Congress of
Europe, Metternich establishes world
Sorry, establishes uh peace in Europe,
okay? And they think this is a great
thing. But then you have the revolutions
of 1848, which threaten and destroy a
lot of these monarchies.
And so after that, what happens? We now
have you have continue continue
continuous wars, okay?
All right? So that's the
So that's what the
um
people That's That's what the elite of
Europe discovered because of the French
Revolution. You can either have your
soldiers go to war or they will revolt
against you. That's your choice.
All right? And that's And And so this
will take us into World War I
in the 20th century.
Okay? So
the peace of Europe is one of major
legacies of the um French Revolution,
but as I mentioned, another major legacy
that we must not
um forget is the increase of liberalism
in Europe at this time. Okay? There are
There are many nations that start to
adopt start start to adopt French
Revolution principles.
Okay? But there are nations who are
forced to adopt French Revolution
principles be like Prussia because they
have no choice if they have to fight a
war. There are other nations like
Austria, which will adopt these
principles later on. Okay? So even
though Napoleon will kill the French
Revolution and Napoleon himself will be
defeated by the Europeans, um the French
Revolution marks a radical turning point
in history. Okay? The French Revolution
marks the beginning of liberalism,
modernity,
uh humanism, a lot of great things that
now define our modern world. Okay? We
would not be living in the world that we
live in today because uh sorry, we would
not be living in the world we live in
today without the French Revolution,
okay? It is probably the most
significant event in
uh human history.
All right. So, let me conclude now
by talking about
these great figures that have emerged in
human history and compare them, okay?
So, as I mentioned at the beginning of
the class, without Robespierre, Napoleon
would not have been possible. All right?
So, this chart shows us how
we compare Robespierre and Napoleon.
Robespierre obtained his power through
virtue and dedication. He worked 18
hours a day. He was completely dedicated
to the revolution. He had no girlfriend.
He had no money. He was not being paid
for his work. All he was doing was to
ensure the revolution would succeed. And
because of his dedication and virtue,
the revolution was
was saved and it succeeded, okay? So,
without Robespierre, the French
Revolution would not have been possible.
Um he was a prophet of reason. He
believed that everyone had the capacity
to reason. So, if you present the our
logical argument, people would
understand it.
Okay? And that was both the source of
his virtue, but it's also the source of
his downfall, because he he could not
imagine that his friends would conspire
against him, because they wanted to
protect their own self-interest, okay?
And the third thing about Robespierre
that's important is he saved the French
French Revolution.
Now, let's compare him with Napoleon,
okay? Who's completely opposite.
Napoleon got to where he was because of
political maneuvering. He was able to
identify
um political patrons early in his
career, and he did whatever they asked
of him.
And then
together, they launched a coup d'état
against the French Republic. And after
the coup d'état
coup d'état succeeded, he betrayed his
political allies. He amassed power for
himself. That's how he became emperor,
okay? So, with Napoleon, he's a great
politician. We think of him We think of
him as a general, but he's really a
politician.
Um
the thing about Napoleon that made him
so successful is his myth-making genius.
He understood that people are looking
for myths, and he knew how to present
himself as a mythic figure,
like the Messiah, okay?
And as a result, he destroyed the French
Republic. Now, what's interesting is
that
if you look at human history,
figures like Napoleon appear always at
the end of a republic, okay? So, the
French So, Napoleon killed the French
Republic, but they have Julius Caesar,
who is of the same personality, okay?
Julius Caesar was able to identify local
patrons very early on and outmaneuver
them as they amass power.
Julius Caesar was focused on creating a
myth of of himself as this unbeatable
general.
And as a result, he destroyed the Roman
Republic. Later on, we will study
Hitler. Guess what, guys? Hitler Hitler
follows the same pattern, all right?
Hitler was able to amass power because
he outmaneuvered his local patrons and
allies. We will We will study this,
okay? Remember, the Nazis did not come
out of nowhere. The Nazis were a force
incubated by the German army in order to
destroy the communist movement. Okay,
and Hitler took advantage of this.
Hitler got to where he was because he
created a myth of himself as a savior of
the German people,
right? And then, he destroyed the Roman
Republic. Right? Why is this important?
Because
it's entirely possible we are living at
another inflection point in history
where the American Republic may be
destroyed.
Trump, okay? How did Trump get get to
where he is? Political maneuvering.
Why Why Why is he president? Because he
has a myth-making genius, okay? That's
really important to understand about
Trump.
Everyone's like, "Trump is a terrible
business person. He's lost a lot of
money."
Trump doesn't understand terror. He
doesn't understand economy. He doesn't
care. He He understands mythology,
okay? He understands how to capture
people's attention. He knows how to
instill an image of himself as a Messiah
in people's minds.
That's what he cares about, all right?
He doesn't need to succeed. He needs to
He needs to act. And then he needs to
present himself
in a way that captures people's
imagination. What does Trump spend all
his time on? He spends all his time
talking to the press.
That's his job, okay? Do you understand?
His job is not to think about economics
or military matters. His job is to talk
to the press and create an image of
himself as a messiah to the American
people.
Okay? So, the question then is, okay,
well, listen.
If we see this pattern, Napoleon,
Caesar, Hitler are the same person, the
results are the same, and Trump is
similar to Napoleon, Caesar, and Hitler,
what's going to happen? I don't know.
Okay?
Right?
But, okay, and this is really important,
if in fact, in the next 10 years, and it
will probably take 10 years, if Trump
actually destroys the American Republic,
okay? Then a pattern emerges
in history.
All right? And if this pattern is
consistent, now we're able to control
history because we're able to foresee
and predict history.
Okay?
So, that's the
idea. Okay, that's That's it. Any
questions? Was Was Was this clear to you
guys?
All right, good.
If Napoleon was so self- self- Why were
the
about
How do you pronounce How do you
pronounce that?
What do you mean in the world?
Robespierre.
Being so obedient for for him.
Okay, that's a great question, okay? Why
did Napoleon succeed where Robespierre
failed? Okay.
Okay, I I So, the difference is this. If
I'm Robespierre, I believe everyone is
capable of reason, right? Therefore, you
have a responsibility to reason for
yourself.
You understand?
I will give you ideas, but you must come
to your own conclusions. You must
act independently of me.
Okay?
And Napoleon's like, "No, no, no.
People don't want to think. People want
to believe.
People want to obey.
If I present myself as Messiah, and I
tell people, "Follow me, and I will lead
you to paradise."
People will want to follow me.
Okay? And and and and people love this
confidence, right? This charisma, this
confidence
of Napoleon. Think of Trump, right?
Maybe you and I think Trump's an idiot,
but if you're a person, you believe that
Trump
he is a genius, because he's so
confident. Right? People are attracted
to confidence. Does that make sense?
People are not attracted to logic or
reason. They're attracted to confidence
and charisma.
Trump tells everyone, "Follow me, and
the world will be fine. We will make
America great again."
And you know, you're like, "Well, that
doesn't make any sense." Doesn't matter,
okay? He's trying to He's What Trump has
done is created a mythology that has
captured people's imagination, and as
such, people are willing to die for
this.
Does that make sense?
That's what made Napoleon such a great
military leader, because he had this
confidence, and people would just have
to follow him, okay?
Does that make sense?
Okay. Great question.
Any more questions?
So, I I don't understand how like
how Trump
is
in the
like what what's his
Okay. Myth making, okay?
Myth myth making is
All right, there's reality. Okay, why is
Trump a myth making genius? Okay,
there's reality, right? This These are
things that you and I
um see every day. And then there's
myths. These are ideas
that we have about how society works,
okay? About how the world works.
Now, objectively speaking, Trump is a
failed business person.
His father was a great business person,
Fred Trump, who built a real estate
empire. And then Trump came along and
took this empire over, and he almost
bankrupted this empire. Okay?
And so Fred Trump was spending a lot a
lot of his time thinking about how to
make money. Like, how do I make a great
business? How do I hire good people?
How do I motivate them?
How do I
steal more money from the government,
okay? So, he was focused on the very
specifics of running a business.
Trump is like, "No! People don't want
that. People want to see a successful
billionaire, okay? And what's a
successful billionaire? He sleeps with
beautiful women.
Right?
I'm going to find beautiful women and
I'm going to sleep with them, and the
press is going to report it, and then
people will like, "Oh my god, this guy
is
a god! Because all these beautiful women
want to sleep with him, therefore I
should give him my money to spend, to
invest, because he's a genius, okay?"
Wha-
What people want is mythology of
success.
That
That doesn't make sense. So, what made
Trump actually really famous is is a
show called The Apprentice. The
Apprentice is a TV show, it's made of
and and and the show presents Trump as
this extremely wise and forward-looking
business person. And he's the opposite
in reality, okay? But what Trump
understands that's really important is
people don't care about reality.
People want to watch a TV show that's
exciting, that's interesting, that's
fun.
So, if I turn politics into a TV show,
and everyone's watching all the time,
they will always want me
to be president.
Does that make sense?
So, they only care about the way he
looks, right?
Right?
Yeah, because
Uh
Yeah, okay. So,
is perception more important than
reality? And the answer is yes, okay?
And the reason why is
reality it is very
um hard. It's very difficult.
All right?
People prefer simple ideas, simple myths
that allow them to better navigate
reality. That's why religion is
important. Okay? So, what Trump's doing
is he's creating a religion
um
he he's he he's creating a religion
about himself, right? And it's it's it's
really the same idea as Napoleon.
Napoleon says this, right? I saw the way
to achieve my dreams. I would found a
religion. I saw myself as marching into
Asia mounted on elephant
a turban on my head and in my hand a new
Quran that I would have composed to suit
my needs. MAGA is a new religion, okay?
Make America great again. Don't think of
it as a political movement, think of it
as a new religion. Now, I'll explain to
you why Trump is so powerful, okay?
I think Trump will be president of the
United States for the next 10 years. It
is very hard to remove him because like
once you remove him, the TV show ends.
You understand? Now, you have to go back
to reality. People don't want that.
People want to live in a TV show.
Exactly. Exactly. That's exactly right.
People want to live in a dream. It's
perfect. Thank you.
People want to live in a dream.
Because that's what makes life bearable.
Okay? Does that make sense?
Okay. That's a great uh question, okay?
So, the argument against this is like
and like Trump is a terrible economic
leader.
And so, with his tariff war against
China, with this with with all of these
policies, it's just it's just it's just
going to make the American person more
poor.
Okay? So, less um money spent, um the
American won't be able to afford a
house.
Okay? So, this is really important, but
um
you have to think about people's
psychology. All right? So, sorry sorry
sorry, let let let let me um write write
this down cuz it's a very important
idea, okay? You have to understand
people's psychology.
Okay.
People
are not thinking are not capable of
thinking in absolute terms.
Does that make sense?
Like, if I if I give you a bottle of
wine, okay? This bottle of wine.
Okay? I and I give you another bottle of
wine.
And I ask you to tell me which which
which is better. You're not able to do
it.
Okay? But, if I told you this one is
$50,
this one is $10. You know this this has
to be better.
Do you understand? So, people's
psychology is very interesting, but they
people cannot think in objectively,
okay?
People can only compare and contrast.
So, let's just say, okay,
trade war.
The American
consumer
is losing
purchasing purchasing power,
right? So, the person is getting more
poor.
But,
if China's getting more poor in this
time, right? So, US goes down,
but China goes down even more,
people are happy.
Do you understand?
Okay? I I I I I know this is terrible,
but that's this is true. I don't have to
make you rich. I I just make some I just
make everyone else poorer, and then
you're happy.
Right? Make America great again.
Make America
great again.
Do Do understand?
Being great is a perception. I'm better
than everyone else, and then I'm great.
I don't have to be I don't have to be
wealthy, I just have to be better off
than everyone else.
So, the entire world is poorer, America
is happier.
Does that make sense?
Okay?
So, that's that's the logic here. Trump
doesn't want to make America wealthy
again.
He just He needs to make make America
a myth again.
You understand?
He wants to create
the myth of a great America because the
rest of the world is either at war or
it's bankrupt or people feel hopeless.
Do you understand?
And honestly,
um he's right, okay? He's absolutely
correct in this matter.
All right? And that explains why he's
doing what he's doing, okay? Does that
make sense?
Okay, great. Any more questions?
All right.
Good. All right. So, uh we're taking a
break,
um and then when we come back from the
break, we start the British Empire.
Okay?